hello in this video I'll be talking
about lambda fudge cloning vectors in my
earlier video I have talked about
plasmid as cloning vectors now lambda
fudge is a different vector type now
this whole system is dependent upon the
fudge vector the fudge vector lambda now
if you know the light cycle of a phage
vector it could be different like one
could be lytic cycle one could be
lysogenic cycle now you can see if you
follow the sequence ABCD here you can
see the lysogenic cycle the genomic DNA
of the fudge is getting integrated into
the bacterial genome and it can be
propagated throughout several
generations so lambda fudge can
integrate their genome into the
bacterial genome now that means the
lambda fudge could be easily grown on
bacterial colonies now let me talk about
some genomic features of lambda fudge
then we can appreciate how this cloning
system can work so lambda fudge has a
genome size of roughly 50 kilo base
pairs now a few interesting facts about
their genome is now one third of the
genome is basically junk so it's not
necessary for fudge propagation or it's
essential lifestyle and the second thing
is only if the genome size reach 40 to
50 tried 53 kilo base pairs only then
the packing take place otherwise packing
does not take place so here is lambda
for genome so what we do in this lambda
phage cloning vector is so there is a
genomic region known as stuffer fragment
that is like chunk we don't need it and
lambda fudge doesn't need it for its
survival so it can be easily cut out and
in the place of that chunk you can
insert your DNA of interest which you
want to clone in this particular
sequence the blue DNA is the gene of
interest or the DNA of interest that we
want to clone now this whole fat
fragment can be automatically packaged
into the fudge factor if we reach the
proper size in this particular example
the bottom one could be only packaged
because it has attained the proper size
add two fragments which are kind of non
recombinant and has not reached the
proper size won't be packaged so the
packaging and the I mean it is like lot
easier than screening bacterial colonies
now here every only recombinant colonies
but before I mean only recombinant fudge
wouldn't be produced nothing else would
be produce because otherwise it won't be
packaged inside the fudge now then once
the DNA is packaged into the fudge now
it would be grown on e coli plate and
plucks would be counted now the only
problem I mean this is a super
convenient method because in plasmid we
can only clone up till 10 KB so whereas
in case of lamda fudge vector we can
kind of clone 23 kilo base pairs which
is lot more so the carrying capacity of
lamda fudge factor is way more than the
plasmid so that's advantage of the
lambda budget cloning system but the
disadvantage that we can think of is
like it's a little bit harder to grow
them in bulk but with advancement in
cloning technology and we can grow them
on bacteria so that disadvantage is also
nullified and as a reason in late 1990s
and 1980s people have vigorously use
lambda fudge or modified lambda phage
vectors for cDNA library or genomic DNA
library so in my other videos I will be
talking about those lambda fudge series
and how they're used to make CD and
expression libraries and all so if you
like my video give it a click thumbs up
and don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you